how's everybody doing no no that's
unacceptable do you guys have a good
lunch guys oh man I had tacos they were
so delicious love it
well it's great to be here in San
Francisco I'm from Greenville South
Carolina I'm at wale on Twitter you can
ask me about that sometime if you want
it is a funny story I run and founded
really good emails which is a place
basically where I started curating what
I thought were best practices for emails
email tends to be the bastion of
marketing teams and as a designer and a
product guy said hell no give that back
so I took it and tried to create a space
where I was able to add you know my
ethics and my interest in emails and
over the last two years we've grown to
be 25,000 subscriber list and it's a
side project so we'll see where it goes
from here the people that are at this
conference you all included are way more
talented than I am so you know you guys
should be up here and I should be
listening but in the meantime I'm having
a lot of fun so I'm really really
thankful to be here the other thing that
I do is I run fathom and draught fathom
and draught is a business first design
studio and I'm the director of that and
again out of Greenville South Carolina
so I want to tell you three things that
are true email is the shittiest ship
that ever it's awful right but
the the reality is that it's good news
because it can become really good
without too much effort like Unicorn
good the other thing that you guys
should know is you should not trust
people who cannot cuss in public
all right it's a brand voice this is
what I want to communicate with you all
today the reason why most email sucks is
because we we are somehow we miss the
point that there's an opportunity to
talk to our
summers like people so I want you to man
oh look at that it's so good oh man
I'm so happy that my kids get to grow up
with gifts so great all right so I'm
glad
thank you for whoever clicked play that
was great um I want you to know this
suck that is an awkward phrase but I
think yeah if I'm careful I can coin it
you know Matthew Smith he's that guy
that coined that phrase no the suck but
it's it's this thing what happens when
you actually know what sucks for your
customers
for the people who are reading or using
your product do you know that now we
create personas and all those kinds of
things but you have you talked to them
have you gone to their house have you
heard their complaints not just about
your product but rather why your product
exists what are they hiring your product
to do for them what are they hiring your
emails to do for them these are the
questions that you know really matter
and can give you a bead on what they do
and really make your product and your
communication with them through email
really count
so can we oh that's awesome all right
speak to what's missing Barbara is
missing it's not okay if you guys
haven't seen season two highly recommend
it here's the thing when we started
really good emails the reason why we did
was that there was information asymmetry
who's heard of that term before okay so
there was a time when selling cars from
a used-car salesman that dude knew more
about vehicles than you could and so he
was able to leverage his information to
basically create a information asymmetry
and make money off of you in that right
now through cars comm and a million
other you know utilities we know as much
or more
about vehicles as a salesperson so
that's changed but where there is
information asymmetry there's an
opportunity for growth and connection
and and real value and that's what we
saw is that with the web you can
right-click you can view source you can
see the entire thing but with emails
it's in individuals inboxes and no one
not no one but very few people were
exposing that how many of you have a
favorites folder in your Gmail account
for emails write a good a good bunch of
you really good emails wanted to be that
we wanted to help people have a space
where those things were public so we
spoke to that that missing content and
then we spoke with a missing voice we
like to cuss we like to be rude we like
to say funny jokes about ourselves and
we like to be vulnerable and say oops we
that up I'm really sorry
what can we do to make it better we like
to talk to our customers and our readers
it's a side project so you know like we
do the best we can and we let people
know hey we're limited human beings
please be human with us all those kinds
of things and that missing voice that
rhetoric ends up making a big difference
so these are the things I want you to
walk away with also by the way the
entire everything I'm saying is all I'll
be sending out notes so you don't have
to take notes or anything like that if
you don't want it's all in a deck for
you so I want you to be able to define
what sucks for your customers I want you
to be able to ask them what are they
hiring your product to do for them with
their time or with their money
what are they hiring the email to do for
them and who do they want to hear from
and don't forget that they are actually
paying you with their time and money
don't waste it all right subject and
preheader you can drive with curiosity
when your dad says would you guys like
to go get a treat that's curiosity and
that's really valuable if you see a
stranger and he says would you like to
go get a treat that's different that's
how email feels to me most of the time
right is like get in my white van no
thanks
so think about how to speak to your
customers in a different manner that
feels a little bit more like dad and how
do you get there you build trust and
that that takes speaking to them like
people so value value when you're
speaking to your customers has to do
with being able to say things that that
are really powerful for them that you
know that you get to convey to them as a
trusted individual so 20 to 25 new
companies that make money that's fluff
subject to eat subject line three things
I genuinely think would improve your day
this is the way I talk to a friend
very different sort of language and not
every company gets to choose that
language or that language but it's
important that you find a voice that is
authentic and how you would speak to
your customers not in a way that you're
throwing information at them but that it
really connects them as people clarity
if you have information that you have
special resources and access to that's
extremely valuable to just simply state
something as it is and the value is
clear to them because your customers in
your email subscriber list they're
looking for that information so you
don't need to be obtuse about it and you
don't need to use gimmicks just tell
them what it is connection is my
favorite favorite thing I'm single and I
want intimacy in my life just letting
everybody know so in email yeah this is
good this is my personal subscriber list
so an email name is amazing no one is
using this as they could including
really good emails these this is this is
my dream um my name is Matthew it's not
Matt and Matthew means something to me
when people call me Matthew it matters
and I have a specific seven letters in
my name that's data seven letters it
starts with an M that's something that
could be used if you have somebody call
you by name
especially in response or when they see
you on the street that's that's my name
it matters so why not use it in that way
instead of Matthew here's 25 new things
bla bla bla you have the opportunity to
use that from name or the name that you
have in your subscriber database in a
way that you would talk to a friend so
rethink that entire thing the next is
location we can guess at somebody's
location it's dangerous but location is
interesting like when you're having a
conversation with a friend and you're
like where are you
that's an interesting moment to ask and
you can ask that and get to know them a
little bit better so what could you do
with location you can show things you
don't have to just spell out Greenville
South Carolina you could grab a map from
you know Google throw it as a background
all kinds of things you could do that
make your customers feel connected
actions have they purchased something
have they left something in their cart
have they looked at something and not
bought it have they stopped being active
like how about a friend that stopped
writing you think about that emotion and
bring that into your email strategy
there's so much opportunity to connect
with your customers as real people and
when you do it'll change everything at
Relay Foods where I was a chief creative
officer our number one most valuable
customers were those who we made a
mistake with on our first order couldn't
figure it out for a little while and
then it was obvious they had a
connection with our customer service so
I'm really sorry man that your avocado
wasn't ripe the way it should be
can I bring you a new one that never
happens anywhere but we did that and
that person became so loyal that it was
just it was their value and their
ability to spread the word and create
more customers was incredible and that's
the opportunity that you can create an
email anniversaries are amazing I've
known you guys for like 15 minutes this
is incredible this thing we have
together right so what could we do with
that what can you do when you say it's
our one-month anniversary or maybe it's
our one-year
these are moments these are things in
relationship you know this as people but
we don't communicate this way in emails
and we can birthdays are incredible if
you can ask somebody their birthday
there's a moment in a relationship if I
just ask you what's your birthday that's
weird I'm not gonna do that but if
there's an opportunity we get to know
each other and then I asked your
birthday it's like oh you want to know
my birthday that's awesome like these
are the things I have in my Amazon list
go ahead and you know purchase but it's
like hey this is an intimate moment what
happens then when you when you let
somebody know it's your half birthday
it's exactly in the middle of the year
we just thought you should know we're
kind of happy thank you for being a part
of this there's a moment of intimacy you
drive loyalty you move from transaction
to relationship if you don't know enough
about them right now just ask people
care about vulnerability say we don't
know as much about you as we want to
know so that we can provide value to you
if you have been acting like the
stranger in the white van that's gonna
be creepy so don't be that way instead
be honest hey we haven't been getting to
know you in the way we should we'd like
to get to know you better
for these reasons what I learned in
being the on the executive team in
design on several products is you never
ask for anything from a customer without
offering them something better in return
and that ethic can really drive you ask
for their opinions let your customers
know that they are smarter than you and
you would like to know something from
them this is an opportunity so if I say
please fill out our survey it would make
us really happy give us twenty minutes
of your day and that's it that is absurd
would you would you stop and and like
somebody on the side of street saying
can you stand here and push something
annoying for 20 minutes and the UX will
be really bad but just keep doing it
just because I asked you to that's
absurd no one would do that so why do we
ask that in our emails and in our
products like we shouldn't be doing that
we should be saying
to a small segment of people listen Lucy
we've gathered together 35 people who we
think use our product in this very
specific way your time is incredibly
valuable would you be willing to answer
30 questions it'll probably take 10
minutes we have $100 gift certificate to
Amazon for you I hope that's worth it
would you be willing to do that you've
just earned a lifetime loyal customer
that's the kind of things that you can
do don't default Wow
I am taking forever on these slides so
don't default don't use the stuff in
your preheader in your subject line
that's just like the first line of the
email you'll ruin it I'm gonna let you
read these things on my deck so I can
keep moving through your from name is
important you might show up for a date
wearing a banana hammock this is
inappropriate just so you know take
notes this kind of thing for a from name
is what we get though a lot we get from
names that don't don't they don't
connect to the brand you have so much
opportunity in your brand to have a from
name that really matters like Freddy
people love Freddy they have an
emotional connection with Freddy people
have an emotional connection with smiles
Davis our our logo our icon
this is Clark Val Berg in four years at
envision he has been the from name in
their emails you can write him back now
my guess is that he has some other
secret email address he doesn't give out
but it sure feels like he's
communicating with me and I have the
opportunity to get in touch with a CEO
and that feels good lead in you have
made a promise in your subject line and
in your brand the question is let's go
back the question is can you keep your
promise okay the lead-in has this
opportunity for you to say hey you
opened here's what we promised we would
give you again like you're offering them
some
thing don't that relationship up
this is a really good opportunity to
follow through you're developing
literally synaptically this conditioning
you're helping them pattern match toward
trust help them do that
the fold is real I'm a designer for me
to say this is like anathema but it's
real just make sure that in above the
fold you are actually providing
information that helps them scroll
scrolling is real but your design your
email should be responsive so that the
appropriate information is above the
fold so they will drive down toward more
content is it working if you have a 2
megabyte image no it is not working it
is failing this is happening do not do
that if you have text that is tiny that
I cannot read I'm 39 I have awesome
glasses but their glasses and I can't
read tiny text please improve your
readability in your email headings
headings are something that your
customers will use to be able to move
through the email so you must obey the
context the context is this at least 70%
of the email is being received in a
mobile context this is a utility context
okay so if I want to go into the grocery
store I'm sitting in line is it
appropriate for me to have an intimate
long conversation with the clerk with
three people behind me no I've had to
learn this I like to talk so the context
for email is utility so make sure that
your headings are such that people can
scan the content you guys I hope you
know this movie it's one of the best
movies ever made so make it scannable
what this means is that use your
headings to be things that get people's
attention and communicate clearly as
they can quickly scan down the email and
then go back to the top and read the
whole thing again all right is it doing
its job every heading has to do a very
specific job every part of the email is
being hired by your customer with their
time
to do a job maybe it needs to be funny
maybe it needs to be intriguing maybe it
needs to be clear and useful you know
that based on your audience because you
got to know the suck alright
body content thank you thank you
content is Jedi you've heard content is
king Kings would have their ass whooped
by the Jedi okay content is Jedi content
as we would talk about here a lot is
imperative to being able to really
communicate with your customers so
couple of questions here one how many of
you send out email newsletters and then
that content just lives in an inbox and
doesn't go anywhere on the web where it
can be used again I'm in that camp right
so we've got to figure out ways to get
that content and get it out there it's
valuable so use it keep in mind that
your content is what people are hiring
your email to do for them and so let's
take care of it if you don't have
something valuable to say then write an
email and say we didn't have anything
valuable to say and so we'd like to give
you a joke today because maybe we should
all laugh a little more like there's
opportunity for that if you just hire
somebody who doesn't understand your
customer and doesn't understand your
product to run your emails you are
failing stop it
why are you screaming so why are you
screaming this is just a beautiful
little image thank you Internet Seth
Godin at a conference called Brooklyn
beta said to me why would you scream at
the people who are just constantly
trying to block out the noise when when
you could just whisper to the people
that are dying to hear what you have to
say it's just always stuck with me and
it's a paraphrase but it's just really
powerful so figure out what it is that
your customers are waiting to hear and
say that directly to them and the people
who are on the fringes let them on so
describe let them fall away and keep
going after that strong organic traffic
curate your content doesn't have to be
original people value your ability to
know good information when you see it
gather it and give it to them that's a
huge opportunity that's what really good
emails is based on promote others you
know there's just incredible ability to
say hey these other guys are doing great
you know next week we're gonna promote
some really cool things that are
happening at appSumo why because it's
cool to be cool
like that's it like just there's
opportunities to do that you don't need
to always tie everything to business you
know right what's missing so I said this
before but this is the thing like maybe
in a legal in a legal context like if
you're a law lawyer firm law firm you
have the opportunity to speak with a
voice that's compassionate maybe if you
are a non-profit you have the
opportunity to speak with comedy that
doesn't happen very much when you're
talking about orphans you know like
there's real opportunity to change
things up to be fresh to speak to what's
missing links links are gifts there are
little opportunities I like to think
about them as passports to travel they
give you an opportunity to go somewhere
either to your site from this email an
open door or to find somewhere new so
let's look at this little gift I
actually don't remember why I put this
given other than that this is the most
amazing gift on the internet and can we
just can we watch that one more time
no yes okay watch carefully this is
incredible scoot
I just I just think that's amazing okay
so but links are gifts maybe that's a
gift to me here's something that happens
a lot click here means nothing it is a
door that says open the door don't do
this please make your links intentional
reasonable and effective and help people
understand clearly this is where I'm
going
CTA I would like to propose that we
rethink the whole way that these things
work this is something that especially
marketing teams drive toward without
reservation they just constant we've got
to have more CTA we've got to drive this
CTA CTAs should serve your audience and
if they don't they are it up
like get to your customers and start
earning loyalty and Trust and you will
watch that CTA
percentage rise but if we are only
worried about the number we're really
missing the point we've seen this over
and over again at really good emails for
us the CTA is exciting when it is it
drives curiosity and it makes people
laugh and they're like what's behind
door number three that's how we do it
for our audience for Walmart who one of
our clients not so much they've got to
be extremely direct about what they do
and they've got to tell the customer in
the CTA this is what's happening now and
that's really helpful that's a service
to the customer twenty-five CTAs not a
service this is going to incite decision
paralysis choose one or two CTAs make it
really clear change up the wording on
your CTA so that you have variation that
you can test and know more about if all
else fails be really good just be a good
human being this is not hard there is
probably only three in this
room I don't know who you are but most
of us are cool I love you people
thank you
you